so right here i have a container of
water that is open to the atmosphere
it's standard atmospheric pressure up
here let's just assume that everything
in our system the air and the water the
container everything is 21 degrees
celsius
now our chamber is or
our container of water is divided into
two chambers a left chamber and a right
chamber which is divided by a
semi-permeable membrane it's permeable
only to the water but not to the solute
in the water and on the left hand side
we have
pure water so it's just molecules of h2o
you could view that as distilled water
while on the right hand side we don't
have pure water we have some sodium
chloride that has been dissolved in the
water and we want to get a little
quantitative in this video so let's say
it is 0.25
moles per liter or to 0.25
molar sodium
sodium chloride right over here
well we know intuitively from our study
of osmosis what is going to happen here
since our membrane is only permeable to
water and the right side is hypertonic
relative to the left it has a higher
concentration of solute we will have the
water going from left to right
but what we're going to do in this video
is get a little bit more quantitative
and thinking about well what is the
potential of the water to go from the
left to the right and to do that we're
going to talk about something known as
water
potential
which is denoted by the greek letter psi
now by convention the water potential of
the pure distilled water when it is in
an open container exposed to standard
atmospheric pressure that is going to be
so psi over here is going to be equal to
zero
bars and as you can see here the units
for psi for water potential are the same
as the units for pressure here we're
using bars but you could use psi or
atmospheres or something else but what
is going to be the water potential on
the right hand side well generally
speaking you can break down your water
potential into sub components and the
what the sub components that we
typically talk about but there are more
are the component due to the solute and
the component
due to pressure this will often be known
as the solute potential and the pressure
potential now because this right chamber
is open to the atmosphere and its
standard atmospheric pressure the
pressure potential in this situation
is going to be equal to zero so our
total water potential on the right hand
side is going to be the same thing as
our solute potential
now to figure out our solute potential
we will turn to a formula and i'll show
you a formula sheet right over here
that's given by the college board when
folks take the ap biology exam but we'll
see that this formula is actually quite
intuitive and related to the ideal gas
law that you first studied in chemistry
it tells us
that
our solute potential is going to be
equal to
negative i and i'll talk about what that
is in a second
times our molar concentration c
times our pressure constant
r now they're calling it the pressure
constant in this context but it's
actually the same r that we see in the
ideal gas law times the temperature in
kelvin
so times
t
so first let's start with i so let me
write this down this is going to be
equal to
it's all going to be negative because
all of these are going to be positive
values so i is known as the ionization
constant and one way to think about it
is for every molecule of solute how many
molecules does it disassociate into when
you put it into the water so if i take a
molecule of sodium chloride we know that
when we put it into water it's going to
disassociate into sodium ions and
chloride ions or into two ions for every
one molecule of sodium chloride so here
our ionization constant is going to be
equal to two
now what's our molar concentration well
we already know that our molar
concentration is going to be 0.25 molar
or we could write it as 0.25
moles
per
liter
and then we're going to multiply that
times our pressure constant which is the
same as the ideal gas constant and that
is going to be they give it to us right
over here 0.0831
liter
bars
liter bars per mole
kelvin
and then we are going to multiply that
times the temperature in kelvin now
what's that going to be what's going to
be our temperature in celsius plus 273
so you had 21 plus 273 you're gonna get
kelvin
and so this is going to be approximately
equal to we're going to have this
negative out front and if we look at our
units let's see we have moles cancelling
with moles liters canceling with liters
and then kelvin canceling with kelvin so
our units are going to be in bars which
makes sense because as we already talked
about that's the units that we're
dealing with here
and so let me get a calculator out see
we already have the negative so it's
going to be 2 times .25
times .0831
times
294. is equal to and i'll just round to
one decimal place so 12.2 but i have
that negative there so approximately
negative
12.2 bars so our solute potential over
here is negative 12.2 bars or it's
approximately equal to that and that's
going to be equal to our total water
potential because the pressure potential
is zero so how do we interpret that well
one way to think about it is you could
almost view it as since it's negative
relative to the left hand side that it
would pull water in that the water if
the membrane is only permeable to the
water is going to go from high potential
to low potential and that's exactly what
we thought would happen intuitively
now another thing that we could think
about is well how would we keep the
water from flowing well then we could
add some pressure potential right over
here maybe we could put a piston
over here and
we could apply some pressure above and
beyond the standard atmospheric pressure
well how much pressure would we have to
apply here to kind of push down on that
water so that we don't have a net inflow
from the left to the right
well imagine if this was 12.2
12.2 bars that we were to apply up here
well then all of a sudden this pressure
potential wouldn't be zero it would be
positive 12.2 and then on the right we
would have negative 12.2 bars of solute
potential plus positive 12.2 bars of
pressure potential
and so that would add up to be a zero
water potential in which case since the
left and the right hand side would have
the same water potential you would not
have a net flow of water in either
direction so as you can see this idea of
water potential allows us to think a
little bit more precisely and a little
bit more quantitatively about these
ideas of osmosis and tonicity